pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouache 90 200 m
trop a vu passer à gauche
droite à fond 200 m
attention attention dos d'âne sur gauche
[Musique]
à droite à la corde attention deux fois
gauche en de dan gauche 90
[Musique]
et qu'est ce qu'on fait pour les pneus
fois l'impasse toute la course avec des
mix d'accord attention attention piste à
droite virage à 60
[Musique]
oh oh oh oui on s'arrête pas ma chérie
on prépare le road-book du rallye ont
fait pas un roman
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour vous avez une courroie oui on va
voir ça tient ne vous n'avez pas vu les
majoraux jacques tous les citoyennes que
cody yao mousser à mon copilote kinésie
à bouaké annie cordier alors vous le
mettez ça chantait on ne vous a pas vu
depuis quand tu es puis l'acropole il ya
deux ans ça ira au poil parce que tu
crois qu'en course on s'arrêtera pour
nous n'est pas un volant du sinn
d'ajustement on n'a pas les moyens
d'être généreux a les couilles
l'avion de paris nathan paris
le roi
ouah mais merci
[Musique]
alors
je mets
l'alu bertrand oui
salut bonjour biais à saly champions
salut alors ton cias et amant par lepage
a dû rater damuseau dis donc
alors c'est japonaise accueillant pas
mal les japonaises mais tentons saint
vincent
non mais vous connaissez le cours du yen
toute façon avec ce qu'on nous donne à
lagence un bol de riz et des baguettes
c'est déjà du luxe a pissé pas en tout
cas j'ai pété mon grand-angle faudra
voir à le remplacer et offrait de
lagence syndicats vont tourner ma
lassitude et coutts a dit qu'à mon
angoisse
t'as pas fini de rouspéter dont ben
ouais faut savoir pourquoi mon papier
n'est pas passé le rouge les tâches du
haut et pourquoi pas l'élysée coûte
chances du roi
bon allez donc y chocs les adore je
mangerai la pureté du sport violée par
le miracle industriels japonais
c'était bien de tout excès nous poserait
un problème nous avons des
responsabilités
notre agence est la troisième du monde
et même la seconde en asie ça me
rappelle c'est sûrement pas grâce à vous
bonjour monsieur
france-roumanie de rugby park ont valu
une place pas je me déplace plus je ne
changerai pas d'avis tu veux prendre
quelqu'un d'autre à ma place aussi vrai
que je m'appelle syndicats je pars pas
non plus allons bon voilà que les
photographes en tranchant souche ne me
suis pas dans cette affaire je vais
jusqu'au bout qu'on se dise à ta femme
qu'est ce que croit c'est pas elle qui
décide non ciao
[Musique]
allez d'abord dit non c'est un danger
plus d'en mourir
pas de bol c'est ma faute
la vraie vraiment
pas grand chose nous envient du procès
les voici mes papiers
juliette majourau le pilote et puis vous
voyez ça n'empêche rien vincent
navailles journaliste sportif mais qu'on
inverse avait la garde contact alors
traversé si je n'ai pas le temps lego
torres est un secret d'état
pourquoi parce que vous ne savez pas
lire les japonais d'avoir quelque chose
c'est un kimono les biens est génial a
bien vivace un bon voyage
oui merci reste à dîner avec volontiers
tapas ces projets pensés pour noël pour
toi moi
je
d'abord et quelque chose non
et c'est tu peux tu me dire tu as raison
qu'est-ce qui tombe est des gens
importants très important ils ont jeté
au panier mon dernier article
un article de toi qu'est ce que tu fais
à ma place faux pas de dégonfler papa il
faut recommencer je t'assure
entrez alors ce travail est coté chef
vincent la veille
c'est tout simple c'est le fils que
j'aurais aimé avoir la faveur de
navailles n'est pas en cause ni même son
caractère mais les prédications nager
n'aurait pas réagi comme lui et bien non
nous ne sommes pas une agence pour
refaire le monde ou le sport
bref pas question de céder devant la
vague
il faut prendre des dispositions pour
clermont ferrand jean voit le petit
stagiaire aucun problème
notre ami syndicats et dieu sait s'il
est pas comme en dessous non plus ben
quoi sa vie qu' il a fait amende
honorable il reprend demain après une
bonne nuit de repos sadique albi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon ça va
elle vient bien cette grand mère vous
aurez des chevaux entre 1500 tours
peuvent fort bien ça t'a vérifier la
garde au sol et la suspension
oui c'est fait didot les solistes
bouclier pas envie de me farcir à savoir
la pompe à eau manifeste son cul pour
aller voir qu'il est tout ça les enfants
parce qu'on en bave demain matin on va
finir à sur place
oui j'arrive
excusez moi je devais pas vous ennuyer
ici
pas étonné qu'elle ait pu vous
convaincre de remettre ça elle a vendu
ses nobles hypothéquer son appartement
c'est elle que monter tout à faire alors
à nice et le chef d'équipage et vous là
dedans pilotage est pas fiable ce soir
n'ont réussi vous aider ben pas tout à
fait pour qu'il laisse dans un rail a
dit cormier pour des biologiquement
incapable venir du febvre vous ne servez
là mais dis moi tu connais vincent a
failli salut jean ma liste à la chance
de mal d'informations major encore un
qui n'aurait que pour les pilotes
j'ai toujours marché en photo alors
c'est sympa de m'avoir appelé je pensais
vraiment voir un personnage votre petit
chef
avec lui et surtout n'oublie jamais
faire court et simple
toujours se demander si le lecteur de
mazamet pourquoi dans d'accord hier pour
taper les tâches devra porter à sa
nectaire et un vrai problème
excuse moi de potes accompagne et vous
j'ai rien contre l'auvergne c'est une
question d'honneur l'odeur est l'heure
de ma douleur ma déchirure est et il
aurait poussé l'honneur jusqu'à
t'écraser devant le patron pour moitié
capituler si ma femme et voilà où
s'arrêtent les grandes luttes syndicales
enfin m'a dit c'est la tête et les
jambes vous voulez un jus de fruit
installez-vous moi les gens c'est drôle
mais j'ai quelque chose qui me trotte
dans la tête tu vas vous amuser un roman
mais ça ne se fait pas tout seul la
compétition des voitures c'était toute
ma vie j'étais pilote d'usiné pendant
trois ans il y avait place pour autre
chose
et puis elle y est arrivée elle m'a
proposé ce pari c'est chouette de bonne
femme de priver seulement damas les
amateurs contre les grosses machines
oui savez ce qui s'est passé sur le banc
dames 1 72 oui pas une voiture à
l'arrivée
pas même notoriété
je peux oui messieurs
bah
allo tonton bon ça va on n'y pense plus
vous marquerez pour le bandama le
bandama
non mais c'est maintenant tu te
réveilles figure le patron a déjà
désigné quelques séquelles très bien
c'est un homme nouveau
un homme qui va vivre pleinement elle
adopte déjà saisi par l'ancienne route
mondiale la grande aventure automobile
non c'est morel
vous ne venez pas d'en prendre un autre
morrell comment est il
sublime
mais dites moi vous vouliez venir
pourquoi
ob hier mon fils
web pour la bande à maj de réserves
marines ou encore consulter le syndicat
et puis je veux une prime de danger les
serpents les abîmes le paludisme et
cette chaleur humide chaleur humide
un vrai bouillon culture ça c'est juste
de déprime normale et ses filières qui
vous rendent pas relayée on vous dira
les verts des plaies en les enrôlant
autour de petits bâtons j'en parlais la
piqûre ya des fois des accidents en
ville en recul tout près de la pierre
qu'elle fièvre jaune
comment trouvez-vous là où la beauté
très dur en effet la pub derniers temps
et la piste est très légal est énorme en
bourbier que les jeux soient sûrs que
nobilis il puisque cette année les
organisateurs ajoutent environ 10% de
piste en plus nous sommes un peu
désavantagé
quand on a une voiture dont la puissance
on a l'habitude allons bien du concours
les pilotes d'usiné notoriété cette
femme-là montrera ce qu'on sait faire
ce puissant
dans le cas des cas restants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
il y a
[Musique]
bagagistes s'il vous plaît non du canton
sans hier sur la place beauvau
vous poser les valises ici
le bonjour les numéros de chambres de
mademoiselle cordier major osez vous
plaît 451 et 452 sont là elles sont
sorties monsieur à elles courent un auto
demain ici il ya une grande course
d'auto le rallye du bandama monsieur
vous avez savoie
sara lee ici
mesdames messieurs c'est aujourd'hui le
grand jour et l'heure h le départ du
rallye côte d'ivoire madame à ce rallye
qui va se courir sur un partout
tumultueux de ça
168 km à plus de 100 km de moyenne
les valeureux concurrents actuellement
sur la piste pour effectuer ce parcours
100 km de moyenne sur des pistes restent
ouvertes à la population
quoi vous pressez jeu doté de 9 millions
400 mille francs de prix et là messieurs
aujourd'hui dans le village le plus
reculé de côte d'ivoire le nom de mika
nam sera prononcée avec admiration et
respect et que l'on de la positivement
[Applaudissements]
spectacle de chant
maintenant j'espère que cette fois vous
avez eu droit de rechange on en a trois
[Applaudissements]
ce soir tandis que j'avais présenté tu
te souviens de galles tu trouvé pas mal
le choix de jean une femme meurt chaque
cas peut-on rendement tu veux
suite
[Musique]
après le départ des notoriétés ainsi
qu'on appelle les équipages notoire
voici le départ du gracieuse équipage
composé de juliette machureau et de
annie cordier ce sont des demoiselles
bien courageux
nous leur souhaitons bonne route et
quand arrive le loin possible pour notre
plaisir à tous
[Musique]
vachon
sa vigueur
ouais
là même où aller
oh oh oh
et vous
le troisième trimestre
à
boukari star
non
m
alors sur un shoot
quand tu sors
léger conjointe été relancée
après
abou
attention
où
300 m vas-y pied dans plus rien sur un
kilomètre
[Musique]
à l'aller wenger
c'est sûr que ton raccourcissent et la
piste de droite juré on doit aller
indiscutablement vers le nord mais où
elle honore la maintenance et la bonne
mettez vous d'accord parce que on est
vraiment pressé on arrivés les derniers
c'est qu'il navigateur c'est moi alors
allons-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dites moi c'est vrai que les finlandais
ont cassé façon nous on va pas se casser
la tête pour des notoriétés le principal
et l'arrivée on arrive à je voulais vous
dire pour demain on peut s'enliser en
travailler grébé méfiance aussi dans la
forêt primaire
merci pour le tuyau ya de normal contre
les civils il faut jouer groupé comme ça
il y aura bien un des nôtres qui sera à
l'arrivée c'est pas très content de toi
n'est pas là pour ça si tu veux mon avis
on n'attaque pas assez tu veux me
laisser faire s'il te plaît puis évite
de me lancer un gauche 90 quand je sais
très bien ce à 70 dont on a promis un
quart d'heure oui ou merde
l'importance est pas cassé en quatre
jours d'une guerre merci
[Musique]
on va sur extra
accor
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que
à quel genre ce qu'ils pensent de salah
je traite pas le crocodile de grande
gueule avant d'avoir fini de traverser
la rivière oui c'est la crise à ces
problèmes à l'excès la cam est mal
charles montgomery et d'humour anglais
ça un seul est un bravo
[Musique]
bonjour bravo pour aujourd'hui
c'est à l'école et auriez fait quoi
les constructeurs et les sponsors
doivent pas être des ingrats si c'était
le cas il ya longtemps que j'aurai ma
maison quelque part au pays basque pays
basque pourquoi parce que du tunnel
malheureusement les sponsors ne peut
rien pour moi j'ai une passion pour les
lanternes rouges et pour nous dit alors
à 10 ans drague
bonjour bonjour ma vie tu es à dîner
c'est prévu et où il ya école demain et
dans ma chérie ya longtemps que je ne
sortais avec tapas et maman mais l'autre
book doit faire des révisions un nid à
raison la course d'abord
[Musique]
oui
noir
[Musique]
et c'est moi
des problèmes à droite
est-ce confirmé saison de merde avec
nous
[Musique]
bon
pour l homme n 3 81 points
attention ornières de son mètre quatre
vingt dix soit rien bordel rien en face
j'en sais rien
vous
si côté gauche non
defossez
[Musique]
où
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en
[Musique]
ah ah ah ah ah ah
[Applaudissements]
mr
[Musique]
et c'est encore une fois
allez les mecs allons-y
et
au stadium et en 20 matchs et des voilà
un petit revendeur mon général à dubaï
où est garé près les général montgomery
la situation paraît qu'elle n'aurait pas
été dans cette situation ventes de
cloche pour l'endive a encore un coup
toutes nos félicitations premiers
arrivants à l'étape de bouaké nous
demandons à tous les pigeons qui est
arrivé de conduire leur voiture au parc
fermé qui se trouve devant l'autel on
nous signale que l'or on est arrivés se
poursuit à un rythme plus lent pour la
première fois sur la dernière
on estime que l'étalement des arrivées
débat sera cet homme grand et les
abandons ce but et nous venons valeureux
train d'apprendre que la moitié environ
37 qui se place des plans en parler des
dix premières a dû abandonner à cause
d'un accident
pascal
la voiture balai nos instances à radio
que les arrivées se poursuivront toute
la nuit
je
[Musique]
optis anne k way retient pas ça s'il te
plaît la langouste ulm comment droite à
3 cet homme bien pourquoi lorsque j'ai
nettement l'impression que la cuisine
sans faire mais on l'ouvrait j'espère
que le téléphone ne l'est pas au revoir
merci
ouais
ne t'en fais pas je m'occupe dit y aller
a un sens
alors inutile de s'affoler sans joie la
course un sacré papier quand même comme
si on y était époux de même 14 rescapés
sur soixante sept partants ce pôle
plaisanterie obama
[Musique]
alors
là
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme quelque chose
ça va oui tu es en forme et ça va j'ai
bien dormi
bah tant mieux parce que c'est pas le
moment de penser à tout moment
[Musique]
non
oh
nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
internet est passible pour ça un
pare-brise incassable accroche toi vieux
fer assistance dans 20 ports
bakou
et
rien sur 300 m
3 3
[Musique]
quel con
et pas de pain
mais non il n'y a pas de fonds
mais maman
[Musique]
je ne marche pas
je
au charbon
[Musique]
oh
bientôt minuit vous devriez aller dormir
parce que vous croyez que je pouvais a
dit dont tu me donnerais sandwich à
n'importe quoi non plus ne m'appelle pas
patron toi et moi on est des larbins
tout ça pour une coupe en fer blanc et
finira tas de ferraille non seulement tu
fais le procès de la formation mais
maintenant tu fais aussi celui du sport
le procès du sport non mais de ceux qui
l'ont récupéré oui là je te suis vieux
frère mais les pilotes c'est quand même
des sportifs ne vais pas le contraire
devant juliette juliette
tu as vu leur est alors excuse moi je
voulais savoir avoir quoi que les
ivoiriens sont tus et qu'ils ont fait
une connerie ça devient vraiment très
intéressant la malchance ça n'existe pas
la connerie aussi annie les écoute pas
tout ce qu'ils écrivent ces débiles
l'exploit comme une oeuvre d'art
l'exploit votre avis c'est quoi c'est
gagner c'est tout seul sur le podium
alors tu viens tu restes oui je viens
vincent soyez gentil si vous avez des
nouvelles fibres
qu'est ce que la sa copine un peu pet au
casque une attaque de polio il ya cinq
ans aujourd'hui elle ne court pas les
règles c'est qu'ils pratiquent
je trouve que c'est ce prêt à manger de
100 points considérablement
on appliquera mais j'étais plus noir qui
lui alors syndicat sud a bon goût amer
j'ai oublié
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu t'en course
on
quand gauche 3e
ouais vue
[Musique]
voilà
j'adore sur un kilomètre on ne sait pas
vraiment eric mois si on ne crache pas
sur un arbre dans mes bonnes pour le
froid
ben oui
notre show pour y asseoir parti de là
finalement c'est un petit pas
attention tous troisième sans carreau
[Applaudissements]
à
assima si beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
à
elle a réduit la dissidence vous rentrer
là dedans
le bandama
[Applaudissements]
j'ai gâché la route dans de dia y avait
ces graphes me dégager la route vers sa
venue à l'hôpital du mali vient
d'arrêter mes droits mais vous êtes
folle à lait du blé moi tout ça hôpital
big mama mais pourquoi moi vous avez une
voiture non il n'ya pas une minute à
perdre ma voiture elle est cachée
il faut l'opérer tout de suite autrement
il mourra il est où votre hôpital à jack
et 5 km par là pas question on le met
dans la voiture en le déposant prochain
contrôle et là ils se débrouilleront
mais c'est 1 250 km je mets une survivre
à aller dépêchez vous
allez tout droit à l'hôpital c'est dans
l'autre sens le premier embranchement à
droite allait droit
et
[Musique]
vous
c
écoutez mes chers auditeurs les derniers
moteurs qui vrombissent souvient le cas
de dire que le rat
coty wahab al dahmach n'a pas failli à
sa première édition la course a été
meurtrier même coup les autorités ainsi
qu'on appelle les équipes nettoient
normal lagarde qui a connu quelques
problèmes encore de l'épreuve notamment
au niveau maintenant c'est cuit pour les
filles elles finiront pas dans les
délais mais ce qu'elles ont fait chapeau
salut jean mes enfants alors ses bras on
n'a pas eu trop ce coup-ci bien par le
terme il un jour
dans les pas de chanter mais aussi john
a besoin
[Musique]
quand j'y vais à moi maintenant plus
personne va arriver dans les délais et
toi tu vas parler d'une édition
je ne risque pas nous sommes en grève et
voilà mes chers auditeurs la dernière
auto est arrivé le rallic audio avant
damas est terminée je vais maintenant
rendre l'antenne à mes camarades du
studio pour notre émission quotidienne
n'est pas une recette de momar béatrice
et si le sport n'est pas mort de saisine
virgule de ces drogues et de son argent
virgules
c'est parce qu'il lui reste encore des
gens capables de le servir et pas de
s'en servir
[Musique]
point à la ligne juliette majoro et
annie cordier ont perdu la grande course
pour ce que nous appellerons avec
émotion entre guillemets une petite
course à faire points voilà ce que
n'aurait pas fait un pilote du sinn un
champion du monde
point final dans la vague terminer mon
pied s'est bien passé j'espère que le
lecteur d'amazon et comprendra
le papier de navailles il est vachement
saignant d'horreur
alors dieu meilleur tour nos barricades
il avait promis un éléphant à son fils
puis stade oukil envoie donc sacré
[ __ ] de papier truite ou trash et
signé navale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
les rideaux
salut je passerai droit
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était mon dernier rallye annie
finalement les amateurs qui a géré
professionnels message n'est pas tête
et bien dites moi comment diète auch
analyse suffit d'aimer les clous ça
tombe bien j'ai envie de me bagarrer les
femmes au voilà c'est quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sinon qu'ils se dépassent sur les
terrains sur la glace y vont jusqu'au
bout le biais de leurs visé le port
[Musique]
tout est champion qu'est ce qui fait
courir tous ces gens dire aux champions
c'est pas la joie c'est par chance au
champion la gagne
de la joie que l'effort
[Musique]
pour les olympiades émulation sur les
stades font rêver qu'à chaque fois tu
réalises l'espoir
[Musique]
boudy mot champion qu'est ce qui fait
courir tous ces gens dis-moi champions
c'est pas la gloire c'est pas l'argent
[Musique]
c'est juste la joie
ou pas
[Musique]